welcome to day two the governor's
capital budget hearing my name is james
gary i'm the state's budget director
and uh
for those of you who were not here
yesterday how this works is we're going
to call you up uh at your scheduled time
uh because this is a noticed meeting
that we cannot put you on before your
schedule time so if things
and quicker than the schedule
predicted then we just take a few minute
break between sessions
so if you're here thinking well if it
goes quicker
i should be there you don't have to be
so just be there at your appointed time
it'll either be that or maybe a few
minutes later but we try to stick on
schedule
so with that i'd like to start
with our first presentation which will
be from the department of environmental
services
good morning
good morning for the record i'm bob
scott commissioner with the department
of environmental services uh with me is
susan carlson our chief operating
officer and uh
nice to meet you in person
nice to meet you as well
so so you should have some handouts from
the department uh if uh if it's the will
of the the group here i will uh briefly
summarize each each uh section
uh
so the first section i'd like to to talk
about is our request for it
infrastructure
uh we have uh
really five subsets of that
the major subset is a what we're calling
phase two or a continuation of the work
we're doing on consolidating our
over 200 separate databases and one
million documents that we have for the
department uh we currently are going
through phase one right now which is the
less than glamorous work of getting
everything formatted in consistent ways
so that they can talk that there can be
linkages with the databases
uh we're very interested in taking that
to the next phase in order to provide
uh more transparent service to our many
customers uh so the one stop just to
give you some background we've
a couple times we've had it's had to be
offline for for various reasons
uh to improve it one of them was for
cyber security vulnerabilities um and we
immediately got
many many calls from from both citizens
looking to to look at environmental data
but also for a lot of consultants a lot
of industry work goes on they depend on
at this point they like the online
service that that provides rather than
having to come in and look at documents
directly uh so for for many reasons
we're very interested in that uh
that work uh
to move ahead on our our customer
service if you will
so that cuts a lot of ways it also uh
is less impactful to staff as we move
forward also the other another part of
this request is for
our ongoing work to upgrade our air
monitoring stations so we have a
network of a dozen stations throughout
the
state where we might measure different
air quality aspects and we report that
to our
citizenry as well as the federal
government uh so you may occasionally
it's less
prevalent thankfully for new hampshire
now but occasionally you hear about it
our air quality action day and that's
that's coming off that network uh so we
we are continuing to to want to do
upgrades to that to make that more
efficient
uh we're also part of this request now
is to include a mobile calibration
unit uh with the march of technology
where we're looking at what we're
calling microtype stations
which will basically be a lot more cost
effective and less energy used etc
the only downside which i don't think is
a downside is
there's no room in the the structure to
actually co-locate calibration equipment
so we want to move to the next
level of that and have a mobile
unit that can do the calibrations and
not have separate calibration equipment
at the different sites
uh
the next issue we'd like to address
through it is our subsurface program
which is code for septic tanks
we have over 48 years of
of uh
hard paper records that
the public needs to get at the
installers need to get at our staff need
to get at
that needs to be digitized so that would
be a that that service would be of great
value to pretty much everybody who's
involved with that type of work
work
um and then our
limnology lab uh is uh
all the work that that's done in the
field that comes back for lab analysis
uh is all currently in a a single access
which is uh an old microsoft product uh
database uh that is not not pretty
particularly functional
again just like our one stop data we
want the public our staff to be able to
readily access
uh that and
that needs updating
and finally our pools and spa program uh
which
uh we had legislation to revamp that
unfortunately as a result of uh
legionella outbreak of uh back in
2018-19
at uh hampton beach where we had some
deaths caused by
improperly maintained
spas
so that's right now we have a single
database and only one person at a time
can actually access we want to have that
so again the public can access it the
towns can do
do some of this work for inspections so
that they can access it uh and certainly
so the public can online register online
and do their certification so
that's in need of work also so that's
part of that it request
item that you see
the next item is the groundwater
monitoring well expansion
so we have a network of
groundwater monitoring stations
throughout the state we use this the
data from that to help us
predict and
monitor drought conditions especially
uh what's
come of that uh the the past two years
we've we've seen severe droughts uh in
especially the north country
uh and
and now we're seeing actually we're
currently in um
lower moderate drought conditions in the
seacoast
those two areas are
are we have gaps in that system so we
don't have as many monitoring wells and
the monitoring wells we have by and
large are not bedrock wells that we
actually need to see so we're
envisioning uh kind of filling those
gaps and that will allow us to help work
with the public work with
impacted communities on a more timely
basis
for drug conditions
the third issue we have is for
the israel river uh
ice control structure and and uh we've
lumped that with which is a half million
dollars we've lumped that with a
hydrologic data collection network which
is i'll start with that one that is
basically
allowing us to do further automation and
and uh understanding of our
uh
flow conditions and uh to help help
manage the dams better and also be more
predictive on flood conditions uh so
that's what that upgrade is is about uh
the
israel ice river control structure is in
lancaster that's a there's a long story
history with that it's actually army
corps of engineers installed it never
quite worked as it was envisioned it's
not been maintained and now we're at the
point now where uh thankfully for d.o.t
is
the bridge downstream of that is now
large enough so it doesn't clog ice dams
and between
the the lack of maintenance uh being in
disrepair and the the bridge taking away
the issue it's we're ready to have that
removed um
right now it's both a public safety
hazard and it is supposed to control ice
it actually collects ice so that's a bad
the fourth and fifth
items are
our state revolving loan fund match for
clean water which is code for waste
water and storm water
and drinking water
so those are long-standing programs
uh typically we have uh requests in to
match there's always a match requirement
for the federal money that comes in
the difference this year is with the
infrastructure bill
there's a significant increase in the
amount of match uh
needed because they're giving us a lot
more money
and i think we all agree that
this is this is money well spent as far
as we don't want to be giving federal
money back
uh the good news too is the the first
tranche of that the 2223
only requires 10 match rather than the
traditional 20 match
uh but that's what that request is so i
do want to point out that uh house bill
4 1421 which was
amended after we had submitted this
includes uh 7.6 7.76 million dollars
out of the state surplus to match so
assuming that signed which i have no
reason to believe it's not going to be
then that request can come down by that
7.76
the next item on our list is the uh
baker flood control dam uh
rehabilitation uh that is a uh
again it's an older dam as i guess you
could say that about almost all of our
over 200 dams we maintain
and that was originally built by the
natural resources conservation service
they have a program where they
will help pay
both some of the assessment and
engineering design work but also
they'll pay up to 65 percent of the
rehabilitation cost
this is a case where originally the work
was scheduled to be done in 2016
uh and we had we had some funds 3.9
million appropriated then
in the march of
time and
and the damn deteriorating uh now the
the uh
cost now that now that the feds are
ready for that uh the cost has increased
so
uh between the 3.9 million appropriation
we have already uh and what the feds are
putting in their 65 percent we still
need uh an additional 11.8 percent uh
million dollars uh fit for that um
numbers our seventh uh request is for
the winnipesaukee river basin
uh so just a reminder that we
run and manage that program we run the
wastewater facility and the collection
lines
for those 10 communities that are
involved
they are this is a
user service there's no general fund
monies in here and there's no bonding
for state monies here uh but it does
obviously being a state state thing it
goes through through you all so they are
looking to re
as part of their
normal
upgrades and replacing of old lines that
are breaking uh they're looking at two
and a half miles of force main to be
replaced on route 140 in belmont and
about 1300 feet of force main in laconia
and
our last
did i miss one here
i guess not no i guess i didn't uh so
our last request has to do with our
office space and our modular furniture
we have
most of our wings on a floor on hazen
drive
have been converted to module furniture
in order to maximize usable space for
staff
in the march of time and especially with
the infrastructure monies we have a fair
number of temporary positions that we've
had to add and we'll be adding
and
we don't want to be
leasing more space for that
we'd like to convert
we have one floor that's not
converted to work stations now so
that will allow us to maximize that
floor
uh by adding module furniture to that
that space
so with that again i i can certainly go
into
as much detail as the group would like i
representative um thank you
other than
winnipesaukee is all the rest of this
it would be very helpful if you
differentiated that
because when you start looking at a 50
million dollar plus or minus request
out of 100 and i think the governor said
125 million yesterday
so which are general funds and which are
other funds
would be helpful i think for anybody
who's trying to put this
whole package together
the only other one besides winnie is the
baker flood control damn rehabilitation
it's 65 federal 35 percent staked
all the rest of the requests are general
or straight as straight-up general funds
our ask is on the total
so we would be um of that total 7.8
million is federal for the baker river
6.7 million for when vasaki is other
funded and the balance is all general
funds thank you
for your
fourth and fifth clean water and
drinking water you have roughly 38
million of general fund revenue with i
believe 281 million of federal funds
coming in
could you just
briefly because we you know as you point
out the time is limited
talk about what specifically that money
is going for what what are you
purchasing
with that uh 310 million roughly
sure again this is match money for uh
federal state revolving loan funds so
uh this provides
low interest loans and with the
infrastructure bill uh depending on the
community it can be up to 49 loan
forgiveness is always a certain amount
of loan forgiveness so these are
drinking water projects so it could be
upgrades to
treatment plants it could be upgrades to
pipes it could be new pipes same thing
for
wastewater treatment
this sounds like a lot of money
our assessment which it is
our assessment though for the needs in
the state is over two billion dollars
so it's all relative i guess right
good morning thank you for coming in
morning um on your i.t infrastructure
plan
are are all of these um you know
individual items working under the you
know an umbrella of this of some
system or are these all individual
so a few things i'll point out since
dennis's
commissioner goulet is sitting next to
you we work very closely with the doit
as part of our overall plans and we we
make sure what we're doing matches uh
their assessments of the needs also uh
and then we also have a planning unit we
set up within the department so we we
are able to prioritize and make sure
it's within the scope of the department
and uh for whatever better words that
way that that prevents what we hope
those two things prevents the left hand
not knowing what the right hand doing
because at the end of the day we want a
combined system that works all together
with and including with a long term
whatever the state ends up doing if you
will i i guess my question is um
you you're asking for a request for
phase two does that does that have
anything to do with digitizing
historical subsurface documents
we've broken that out
right
so i i guess my question then is
um
this is coming in as one ask for 6.5
million
could you
and
if it's possible that
you know you could
be funded for some but not all
yes in our um in our original submittal
um the um
we had a detailed memo explaining each
piece of it
um the one stop phase two is 5 million
fifty one thousand
the air monitoring is three hundred and
ninety six thousand
um the digitizing of the subsurface
documents is estimated at eight hundred
thousand dollars
and the updates to the laboratory and
pools and spas is 300 000 in each of
those individually 150.
um
um so thank you for that that's actually
very helpful to to see the line items
and it is a very detailed memo
um
my question is about the srf matches am
i right those are
um
this isn't in your best interest to
answer correctly but um are they
scalable
that is to say we can
you know if we did and i'm not
suggesting this but we did half of it we
would get half the federal money if we
did two thirds of it we get two thirds
of federal money
correct uh and again and you have a
backlog of like 2 billion and this would
get you 300 million of that 2 billion
right right and again the the we is the
communities and the water systems this
is money that we don't keep it goes out
to the water systems for projects
and it's um
you said there's a backlog of about two
two billion are those literally
identified projects or
no that was an assessment with that
without going without going into
gee we need to expand here for future
development but with just the existing
infrastructure we have that that was the
the current assessment of the needs you
know again
not to go in too much detail but
you know when there's a geyser on main
street is not probably the the most cost
effective way to fix that but we know
the condition and that type of thing so
we work with the community so that's
basically a an assessment but not uh not
uh here's itemized people are ready to
give us anything
if i could we did uh
we do an annual
uh solicitation for pre-applications
last year we got
just for people ready to actually
execute then we had
over a billion dollars in requests for
applications last year
nice um
uh
how does this dovetail it all into the
um
you know the state through the through
the drinking water trust or whatever
whatever we call that i don't remember
anymore sure um is sort of expanding and
improving the state's
drinking water infrastructure and
more pipes fewer wells probably but um
does this dovetail a little bit with
that it does the same our staff work
very closely we have the drinking water
groundwater trust fund which thankfully
can be used to do things that this srf
can't do like expanding for economic
development that type of thing uh we
have been using arpa money and matching
the srf to make it go farther also so
we've been sending up that solicitation
for a billion dollars we've been with
the amount of money we have which is not
as much we've been sending and we have
right now we have 233 offers out to
different communities saying here's
here's good news you asked for this much
alone we're going to be able to give you
this much an arpa grant and this much in
the loan to kind of make it go farther
so so
to answer your question the same staff
are all working together so some
communities gee what you want to do you
really can't use this funds but you can
use that fund so we're we're kind of
leveraging that and we strongly
encourage them also take advantage of
other funding like
royal development funds or northern
borders and kind of do a mix and match
do you have a sense of the the
this is an unfair question i'll preface
it by saying that do you have a sense of
the total value of the state
the combined uh
capital worth of the state um
water infrastructure
no
okay
but a lot more than two billion
good morning i have two two questions
one you had said that this request this
is on the clean water drinking water as
well um that this is an increase over
the last biennium
primarily as a result of the federal
infrastructure bill
this request totals around 38 million of
just those two how much of of an
increase is that over the last capital
budget request
good
any estimate on that
it's more than double okay i
essentially we are getting um
more than the supplemental
funds we're getting through the
infrastructure bill as more than double
our normal grants
and then my second part is on the second
bullet it talks about that the committed
funds must be identified prior to epa
awarding the grants what's their
timeline that you have to have those
projects in so they could do those
awards is there a set time at a certain
point in a year there is a set time but
it's based on the federal budget and the
federal budget right now is
not done
and on a timely basis so it varies
so um we are right now on the fy 22
we have exactly three months left before
we lose those funds
thank you very much
i'd like to
invite commissioner mason and fish and
game
morning for the record i am executive
director scott mason new hampshire
fishing game i brought with me um
josh davis uh chief of our facilities
and lands division
um
bro we would like to request a million
dollars for our for design
of our final hatchery construction
project that we've begun
um we have
applied and received 55 million dollars
of opera money already
to construct two hatcheries
um that will bring us
um we the plan was is that we would
finish up constructing a third hatchery
and re and rebuilding a fourth hatchery
um
so at this point we would like to
request a million dollars to do that
final design work on those two
hatcheries
we've also requesting two hundred
thousand dollars for our hatchery
infrastructure improvements
um
we will be building
our hatcheries are fairly well worn out
and for example this year we spent about
265 000 on major repairs at our
hatcheries
and basically we're trying to change the
tire without stopping the car as we roll
down the road we're trying to maintain
our production as we go so we know that
we will have some major repair work to
keep
the existing hatcheries in production as
we construct new hatcheries to replace
them
um our the two the two that will be
building uh the finish date is
anticipated being december of
2026.
uh the next request is for 250 000
for headquarters roof repair
like some other state buildings we have
some major leaks in our roof at our
headquarters building and um
we would like to get the trash cans out
of the hallway and and um try to fix you
know try to get the roof leaks fixed
we also have had a problem at our gibner
center the hugh greg coastal
conservation center down
uh in greenland
um
that was built with a
heat pump
system
and and two of those pumps have failed
and we believe the third one is aging to
the point where it would make sense to
replace all three
and then our last request is for fifty
thousand dollars to go in and replace
what we call a coast guard dock which is
where we
um house our boats that we use on the
ocean
are there any questions
yeah i have
one with with on the hatcheries with the
aging hatcheries and the problems you've
had
in in
maintaining them because of their age
have you noticed or have the state
notice any drop in production
from them that would be noticeable to an
avid fisherman
well so far we've been able to
get there fast enough to fix problems
that would create those types of drastic
drops in production um this year our big
issue were wells you know well you know
well pump failures and working with our
contractor we were able to to keep the
wells running and keep the water flowing
so no we have not directly from
equipment failure one of the big
problems we have at our hatcheries right
now and have continued to have as pre as
predators
there's a family of otters over in new
durham that are quite happy and fat
right now and eight six thousand trout
inside of a week
wow
other than the um hatchery design all
the rest of the the items you listed are
going to be funded
fish and game fund okay and but
in a follow-on to the hatchery
if you get the million dollars the
assumption then is that the legislature
and the following biennium will pony up
30 plus million dollars
can you um can you talk a little bit
about um if i understand what you said
before
and i'm ignoring the fish and game fund
pieces and focusing on the hatcheries um
you're getting 55 million of arpa funds
a million would be for design
and your estimate is that at that point
you're about probably 30 million short
although we'd know more from design does
that mean that design and construction
and replacement of the hatcheries is a
total of about
about 85 million then you're about
halfway there that's what we're
predicting right now it'll be a total of
about 85 million we're still in the
process um
last year
we received a million dollars to do
technology research
the issue came the the issue at hand is
is that epa set our discharge permit or
neptune's permit at 12 parts per billion
that's to my knowledge that's the lowest
that they've ever issued anywhere in the
united states
and we're in the process of trying to
make sure before you know before we
build whether or not if we can meet that
type of a discharge uh so we're actually
doing some pilot we're beginning some
pilot studies right now at new durham to
see what kind of technology and what the
we may discover that it's going to be
too costly to meet those types of a
requirement and that would force us to
look at
moving a hatchery to a new location
you need to remember these hatcheries
you know the youngest one is a little
over 50 years um the oldest ones are
well over 100 years old
when those hatcheries were cited nobody
really thought about discharge that was
never that was never a thought it was
more about you know water source and in
the old days in in the early days was
also about gravity because you know you
just didn't have electricity in some of
these rural areas um
so you know like in new durham we've got
a wonderful facility with a wonderful
water source and it's completely gravity
fed
as i imagine you folks can imagine right
now our hatchery in
milford is well fed and
the electric bill there is climbing uh
rather quickly right now um so
you know it does come out as a balance
in a management you know management
issues
if you were to just to help me sort of
understand a couple of questions one is
how many hatcheries do you have overall
but
um
to dovetail that in
what are you doing with the 55 million
what are you not doing without the 30
million
and um just in the back of my mind and
this i know this is stupid and i
acknowledge that this is probably a dumb
question but
you're doing a million for design
but you're doing 55 million
which you're presumably using for some
construction too correct wouldn't you
have done the design first and it it
feels to me like the design which you
know let's say it gets approved you
won't get it for a year
it feels like that's in the middle
yeah and
so
what's going on
we have a million dollars doing the
research to figure out what the
technology is going to be out of that 55
million
we will with money in there to design
the two hatcheries that we believe will
build with that money
this third request will be money to
design the third and rebuild of the
fourth hatchery i believe when we're
done we're probably going to have three
hatcheries three new hatcheries and one
rebuilt hatchery
is what our goal is right now
okay
hey
good morning good morning sir how are
my name is kim mckay and i'm the comment
at the new hampshire veterans home i'm
pleased to be here to discuss our uh
fiscal year 24 26 capital budget
requests
today we'll talk a little bit about our
strategic plans and then describe the
request in detail
the new hampshire veteran home i'm sorry
let me introduce matt sorry hi matt
henry director administrative services
good morning
the new hampshire veteran home was
founded in 1889 as a home to care for
aging civil war veteran population
today what we look like is we're a
facility that we have a 250 bed capacity
license wise we are budgeted for 225
however due to current limits around
staffing as everyone else in long-term
care and healthcare experiencing our
current census is 123 veterans
with the staff that we have right now we
could probably go to 130 but we would
not be able to
house more than that safely with quality
of care
unlike other long-term care facilities
in the state we are certified by the
veterans administration
most state
all other state facilities are cms
certified
the va certification provides us with a
per diem payment uh two different rates
one is a basic rate which is a standard
rate for all veterans and one is called
a prevailing rate which is a higher
standard of rate based on service
related disabilities
the mission statement of the veterans
home hasn't changed for decades it is to
provide the best quality of life for
for veterans with dignity honor and
respect
the capital budget
project request we are presenting this
morning will ensure that we can safely
care for our veterans and meet this
mission
our fy 2426 budget invests over four
million dollars into critical life
safety projects as well invest in our
capital
excuse me our supply and service
infrastructure to bring us to into a
post-pandemic environment
my strategic priorities include
investing into health life safety
requirements maintaining our steady flow
of the per diem rate
payments preparedness to bring us into
the post-pandemic world and purchasing
needed equipment to grow the census when
staffing allows us to do so we have
seven we have six on the file here but
we have a seventh uh capital budget
request that has come up and i will let
good morning matt henry director of
administrative services uh what i'll do
is i'll skip over the the slide that
says current projects if you have any
questions i'd be happy to answer those
but really i wanted to talk about two
kind of buckets
so the first bucket is state fiscal year
24 26 request back in april we submitted
to the business supervisor
six capital projects that met the
commandant
strategic priorities
about a week after we were high-fiving
each other because we were happy that
the capital budget was submitted we were
happy with the all the requests um and
our va survey occurred so we had various
findings we were pretty pleased with the
survey in general but one finding that
um
we couldn't wrap our head around was one
regarding a sprinkler systems in closets
so particularly in our tar south area
the finding was published in may
and we we contested the finding hoping
that they'll
the va would come to their census um and
use a little bit of reasonableness uh to
the to the finding uh frankly we lost
and frankly the va was right uh so the
we we um
our
thesis statement if you will was that
there was a small room exemption for
hospitals that we tried to
um
argue
the va came back and said hey
silly you're not a hospital you're a
nursing home you are a home there's
combustible materials in closets thou
shalt
install sprinkler systems
so the
the amended project list is on that
state fiscal year 2426 project list
proposed
and
really we wanted to shimmy a number one
priority um in installing sprinkler
systems building wide so before i uh go
into project project detail i just kind
of wanted to set the stage on why we're
coming to you and we did notify the
governor's office preemptively
i just want to say that the reason why
that is now risen to our priority one is
that we are certified provisionally
right now the va has given us a
provisional certification which means we
will continue to receive our per diem
rate payments
but we must be fully certified to
continue getting those payments which is
a large portion of our budget so we have
to become into compliance with that
requirement and again that's why we
challenged the requirement um we have
they have said no you must sprinkler all
so obviously our preference is to to not
throw out our tar self modernization
project but we understand that if we if
we had to select one uh that is one that
could possibly be deferred
because it's not a life safety project
so now i'll go in just briefly um
project by project so first i'll i'll
talk a little bit about the building
wide sprinkler system upgrade
so on on the slide
it shows the where the sprinkler system
should go and where the sprinkler
systems are
so the fire code does require that we
install these sprinkler systems and when
doing further investigation throughout
the building we realize that
our entire building requires sprinkler
systems not just the tar self
area that the va
identified
so the next next project is site-wide
drainage and water safety improvements i
had the privilege of watching yesterday
uh um commissioner arlinghau's uh
testimony for the department of
administrative services and i think he
you referenced uh six bucket leak and 12
bucket leak
so um what what i would argue i'm gonna
you're gonna wish that you never uh
referenced that right
but i think the
the way i would describe this is if you
have a six bucket leak in that corner of
the room six bucket leak on that corner
of the room six bucket leak on that
corner of the room and a six bucket leak
on that corner of the room you have a 24
bucket leak
um so
the veteran's home has major water
issues we have water
every time there's a heavy rain storm
there's a water there's water issues at
another part of the building this
capital project really is intended to
fix the water problem at a macro level
as opposed to a micro level so this will
require some investigative work this
will require some pretty sophisticated
design but we really want to take care
of it once and for all so these two
photos show that the photo on the right
shows the water protruding from a
communication conduit thankfully not
electrical but the photo on the left
shows an electrical generator that the
so the next project is an entryway life
safety improvements this is this one's
relatively simple it's already designed
but the
the
here at the veterans home we have metal
roofs in two-thirds of our building and
there's hazardous
snow
you know snow runoff that happens at
each entrance so this is really to
construct some entryway protective areas
so we don't have to use caution tape
like we currently do
the next project is a is really a phase
two of a previously approved project for
2018. it had to do with camera systems
and electronic security systems these
these badges get us entry into the uh
into the veterans home
we prioritize camera systems in 2018
so we really have a lot more work to do
with regard to
enhanced security system
access we want to do our ledoo area
currently we have keypads and
combination locks as well as
the next project that i as i mentioned
is a candidate for deferment
is our tar south modernization project
you walk through the veterans home and
there are and we're very proud of how
the veterans home looks however there's
one area into our south that really you
walk in and it looks like a hospital and
the next project is a medical lift
installation this is one phase out of
many we want to incrementally install
ceiling lifts throughout the building
our
our admissions committee uh is very
concerned with uh admitting residents
and frankly they'll they
get larger uh when when they're admitted
and they
become bariatric after after some time
so we want to install 11 lists per lifts
and the final project
is a warehouse and vehicle storage
building
our warehouse is undersized it's it's we
essentially want to double the size of
our warehouse
the warehouse was originally constructed
as an emergency operations building and
the uh
the
area is overcrowded
we have supplies
and vehicles stored all over the
building some of the photos
are
we show recreational equipment that are
stored in boiler rooms we have
vehicles that are stored in maintenance
uh maintenance bays
and we we really need additional storage
space in order to
a
be prepared for the next pandemic when
it does come um so we can have a not
stockpile but a little bit of surplus
supply in ppe
as needed um but even that aside we uh
our our warehouse is cramped so with
that i'll open it up to any questions
you might have
thank you
uh
my question relates to the sprinkler
system and just want to be sure that
you weren't in violation of any local or
or state regulations this is the the the
mandate to have the sprinklers in the
closet is strictly a va
mandate
so the answer is yes and no
so the the yes answer is we were we were
in violation because the code does in
fact say that sprinkler systems at
nursing homes require our closets in
nursing homes require sprinkler systems
our v our
fire marshal having local jurisdiction
interpreted us as a medical facility to
be exempt from that under what's known
as a small room requirement the va
disagreed with that
so we are not in
danger of being shut down because the va
has no jurisdiction over that but they
they have the power of the person they
can withhold pretty in payments okay sec
follow-up to that is did the va give you
a time frame on when you had to have
this
in before they cut off the funding so
they come every april to uh do their
survey their annual survey we have a
provisional certification into the next
survey which is april
we wrote in our corrective action plan
that we would not be able to get this
done until the fall of
knowing that we would have to wait for
the process to go through
so what they've done is given us a
provisional certification they will come
in april they will find us again that
will be a deficiency we will then again
uh be on the record for and we'll have
to show the progress as we go so if this
is approved we will show them that a
progress and we'll do that all the way
through we will get another deficiency
in april because it would not be
complete by april but there would be the
expectation of it being completed by the
uh fall of 2023 or it would affect our
okay well with the timing with this
money and that it would be coming july
1st 2024.
how does that would that complicate the
issue or should we look for other
good point
yes
so i think that was an oversight i i um
we'll have to work with the va to amend
our
i'm sorry no i think i think we're
correct so so
fy24 begins a year from now so i think
no we're good we're i'm sorry um so we
are hoping to get first on the priority
and look at das uh so hopefully we can
if we take the design out of hide we can
begin to execute the project july 1 of
next summer
sorry i had to talk that through thank
you it's always an issue with fiscal
years right um
you're like which one ends which year
and which begins which year um
so uh two things one is that uh first of
all um commandant welcome to your first
capital budget hearing um so you seem to
be doing quite well though um and it's
not that shocking to me that um
your excellent staff would have the
title director of administrative
services
i suspect that makes the makes it just
naturally a good stuff
so anyway um building wide sprinkler
system upgrade why not it strikes me as
being a fairly urgent thing and and
you're right capital budget you you know
a year from now you might get funding if
everything goes it sounds like you
probably will
if i were a betting man um but
um it feels to me like this is the kind
of thing where
because of its
quasi-urgent well it's urgent rather
than emergency nature that maybe you
could approach gopher about
about using arpa funds for and i'm sure
i don't want to speak for gopher or arpa
funds but i think it's something where
you you know you might be able to get
started uh nine ten months earlier than
you would otherwise
so i'm just not sure
what the code would link to doesn't
there have to be a coveted link to
gopher i'm not sure what that doesn't
why don't we talk
sounds good yeah and i think it's a
thing because they're they're
god knows we're doing lots of things
that don't have a
uh i don't want to say this federally
but there's not a direct covet link
i think if we can have it resolved
earlier the better because in april
again that'll show as a deficiency for
our facility and so it puts us at risk
every single deficiency puts us at risk
for losing our per diem rate
it feels like something we could
certainly pitch them on so thank you but
that was the big thing so
i just wanted to add one thing and
you're right up um
you mentioned that you could work on
design
sooner do you have funding available
in the current biennium to help offset
any of that i don't know how much the
design cost would be but to help offset
on the sprinkler system
do you know how many closets
you have offhand that need to be
sprinkled uh 300 building wide
and
um
and and does your estimate of
is that for just adding
piping and sprinkler heads to the
closets it's also involving incidental
work uh presumably we'd have to do some
ceiling work hire a contractor in to cut
holes in ceilings and things of that
nature
but the estimate doesn't include any
rework of the existing sprinkler system
no
would the
heads that are in the closets be fed off
of the existing sprinkler system or
would there be a new system just for the
closets
my instinct says it would be fed off the
existing system but i would defer to a
seeing it see no other questions thank
you very much for your testimony thank
okay we're going to take about a
12-minute break here and we'll be back
at 10 o'clock with the department of
education
but i knew peggy over the years so
congratulations
there's
so it came from a special formula that
to be honest is a mess but putting that
aside it took a year to figure that out
but that so it says 1.2 there's a
maximum
but
that's really more
like all those things that were just
generally you know what you're saying
about you know some other things that
existed in revenue
you would normally do these things right
we haven't tapped into hardly any of it
exactly that's exactly what it's for
exactly yeah
should we just reach out to the program
you
good morning commissioner
good morning for the record frank
edelblut commissioner of education
tammy vallancourt cfo for the department
so i'd like to begin by
discussing our first two projects which
in some sense are linked
and these are two projects that are
really centered around
ending
what i've referred to as the nomadic
existence of the department of education
and i can go into some of the details of
that if that's important for the
committee or is everybody familiar with
how we were displaced a couple of times
from our present facilities
yes yes okay
and so the number one project is
a project to acquire the granite state
college building
on hall street in concord that is the
building that we are presently in and
leasing from the university system of
new hampshire
uh we are occupying three of four
flights or four floors in that building
we are also leasing space
um in concord uh for our special
education um
unit as well um if we were to acquire
the building we would take over all of
those floors and we would be able to
consolidate all of our educational
activities into that one building which
would include the special education unit
that we are in is in uh third-party
lease facilities right now
as well as our adult education and our
career and technical education
units that are presently in the walker
building
um and so this
uh price that we've put on here
obviously would be something that would
have to be go out and get
actual appraisals
but this is a an amount that we put in
here that um was agreed to for purposes
of the capital budget process by the
university assisting and working with
kathy provencher
um so we feel pretty comfortable that
you know it's not a it's not completely
pie in the sky
you'll see that the second
item that it goes along with that is if
we don't
achieve item number one
then there will be additional costs
associated with allowing us to reoccupy
the facility that we have we don't have
a complete estimate as to what that
would look like because
the some of the asbestos remediation is
ongoing and is even as we speak out for
uh proposals to replace the ceilings
that are in there
but we've also got
a previously approved capital project
to replace the bathrooms which were in
significant need of upgrade
as well as some elevator work uh because
the elevator is uh is antiquated and uh
frequently breaks down and we end up
with people stuck in there as well as um
when there are heavy amounts of rain uh
we generally end up with about a foot
and a half of water in the bottom of the
elevator shaft which make it difficult
to to work with
so these two projects
go together
in terms of trying to
sustainably
locate the department of education and
avoid again the nomadic existence that
we have going on right now and so i'll
pause right now before i go to the next
project
okay
my question is
who currently owns the building is
university systems in new hampshire
correct the current building is owned by
the university system of new hampshire
okay so if you transfer a payment from
department of education to them it would
be all in the family yes
and
maybe this question is
directed better to you but you the the
the building you had to vacate because
of the asbestos problems what what
what's happening or what has happened to
that building so
my past neighbor when i was at dra is
that right okay so um at present the uh
the flooring um asbestos has been
mitigated um the ceiling asbestos was
uh the asbestos has been taken out and
now the ceilings have to be replaced in
there
when they were in the process of working
towards that replacement
they were had to look at the light
fixtures and they noticed that the
wiring is not decoded as well
so then i think at present we're
basically trying to figure out what is
it going to cost to replace that wiring
and then be able to put the ceilings
back in
and so that is
what's happening there
that would not include the renovation of
the attic area that is referenced in
this particular capital item which would
allow us uh the room to be able to put
everybody back in there uh albeit in a
very inefficient kind of configuration
but we could get ourselves back into
that facility
and then there would be ongoing projects
we'd have another
um i think it's about 600 580 000 of
work in the bathrooms
um as well as elevator work so i think
what you find is as we begin to
accumulate some of these costs um we're
you know approaching in the several
million dollars of of work to make the
building occupiable not an efficient
facility but occupiable um and so the
question is is it better to just have
the granite state building and then
have a longer term plan for this
particular facility
representative
are you wed on
hall street um we're currently looking
at a large building
to lease in concord with the potential
so
i
i'm not sure it
would have room for them
it
like if if we don't do anything else
yes we could have room for them on on
the other hand
i think this is worth saying that
so much of the state's infrastructure is
you know i'm going to use london as an
example and it and it really sounds like
the commission is talking about a comedy
of errors but it's not it's it's how
these things work we you know we try to
renovate buildings with people in them
laundering happens to be one of the
three or four worst buildings
um
although probably not the worst building
but
we don't fix stuff because people are in
them
and it's funny somebody said to me well
now that it's empty
ish
um
i mean nobody's working there let's cut
the whole thing and start over and i'm
like that's a great idea we should do
that um do you have any money
and no neither do i okay and
what you ought to do
with all of the buildings on campus is
you know in the in the early 90s they
did was spalding they essentially went
back to the brick
and with dra i mean look at dra and i
you know i can say this because lindsay
isn't here but
um it's the nicest building in state
government and um
and it you know it's unfortunate that
you know just just because you happen to
work there you get to work in a gorgeous
in a
lovely building and you happen to work
at the department of education you work
in a dump
and we need to get beyond that but
you know those buildings are so many
things in them and asbestos was you know
the wonder drug of the year you know
kind of like you know cocaine in 1910
and um
and it's in everything and and you know
uh you know we we run into problems
because we fix things i mean the reason
the asbestos came out is somebody fixed
something
um and it wasn't us by the way because
we know where the asbestos is so we
wouldn't have done that my department
but somebody fixed something they're
like oh i didn't know that i didn't know
you couldn't drill through the walls but
you know i work in a building today
where where
sherry's office every wall says do not
penetrate
so more specifically to your question
we're not wed to that particular place
but we're just led to an office building
that's conducive to the work that we're
trying to do
but it's a good spot and would be a good
deal and we're unlikely to find 50 000
square feet of office space in concord
in good shape
at that price
anytime in the near future i mean it is
convenient because it is right off the
highway we have about 7 000 um unique
visitors every year that come to the
department for various programming
it is set up with um
you know two classrooms and another kind
of learning space that allow us to
facilitate uh trainings many oftentimes
that we hold for educators as well as
allowing you know some of our educator
associations to use some of those spaces
we are able to host the state board of
education meetings there um and so in
that stan in that sense it has worked
something that doesn't always get
considered is that nomadic existence is
expensive on the doit side as well
there's a lot of opportunity cost went
into moving frank and team around um
during the last
year or so
so the next
projects that i want to present to you
are two of our cte builds and you have a
handout
that kind of lays out where all of our
cte centers are
as well the renovation schedule so that
you can see historically where we have
done some of those renovations
the present facilities that are up right
now are the sugar river valley which is
in newport as well as the winnisquam ag
program in tilton
sugar river valley is the first one for
around a little over 11 million dollars
that has already received the community
support so they've already had a vote on
it and so they are prepared and ready to
move forward with that particular
program how winnisquam is moving forward
but has not yet been approved locally by
their community
but they will be working towards that
uh commissioner
is that this funding is at the 75
percent i i realize the law says between
50 and 75 but i'm assuming that this is
at the 75
level i believe it is but let me turn
around and confirm
yes
which actually works out well to make
sure that local communities have skin in
the game in terms of making sure that
okay
and then our last project on our list is
our pre-engineering three hundred
thousand dollars which we use in our
education programming for project lead
the way uh is the principal deployment
of that which is a
stem-based engineering program that we
use um in the schools and this acquires
the equipment for those programs on an
can i ask a question about the cte um
funding i um
i like the renovation schedule chart i
hadn't seen that before and it's um it's
it's kind of neat because it explains
the sort of vision of what's been going
on
um
it's a dumb question is there's nothing
in 2223
why did we skip that
so as we approach the end of the list um
really what we're focused on is
communities that are ready to build
right so the community itself has to
uh bring the project to us they might be
in the queue and if somebody says we're
not ready in the queue then we just
accelerate the next person in that queue
forward and so at that particular time
there were not projects in there as well
as i think for that period of time you
had the
hudson cte center that um if you recall
this is one of those projects that we
had
it spanned biennium we did part in one
biennium and part in the second biennium
um that's the will for wilbur h palmer
center in hudson so it says 21 22 but in
fact that a lot of that took place after
that
about
25 of the project rolled over into the
the second year
one of the things that's interesting is
the way that this works is yeah you know
you had the original build schedule like
starting back in 1974
and then the way that we have renovated
these uh centers historically you know
starting back in the 2003 time frame is
really just got back in line
we are approaching the end of this list
and i'm not really sure that just uh you
know the elapsement of time is the right
sequencing for when to invest the next
thing um really what we need to be
looking at is a more
um
you know investment oriented approach uh
that basically says we're investing in
the kind of programming that our
students need and so we would look at
programming in the individual centers
and invest in the programming that make
sure that our students are trained in
the skills that they need
we do that when they come up in the
queue like we're making sure we don't
invest in programming you know that that
doesn't happen anymore
some examples of that is
you know we're not interested in
horticulture programs anymore uh we will
do plant science some of these large
greenhouse operations but it's a whole
different type of pedagogy that's taking
place
as an example marketing programs which
generally in the past looked a lot like
retail stores
those are not programs that we tend to
support because marketing today is big
data and amazon and trying to modernize
the education so that the students
coming out have skills for the 21st
century
it's a and so this chart here on the
renovation schedule that's ever that's
all the cte centers correct and um
i i just want to say this because it's a
you know historically there are a lot of
people who go the government can't
commit to a 24-year plan
on anything
and um
and be trusted right and
we did
yes
and it's it's it's kind of a neat thing
any other
questions
okay
next up i'd like to invite the lottery
commission
good morning jim doris cfo for the new
hampshire lottery commission good
morning
uh so you'll forgive me we haven't done
a capital plan before so i haven't done
this so bear with me um
we have a project that comes in just
under 800 000 it's made up of three main
areas
um first area being quite vital uh
is a replacement of our generator system
uh the lottery is uh
excuse me we're dependent on generator
in case of power outages or anything
obviously to keep our systems going but
it's not just for in the case of running
the local lottery it's also running the
games included in muscle and tri-state
games which are nationwide your
powerball mega millions
and if we're unable to run our processes
at night that literally halts the whole
so with our generators over 30 years
right now
it's not much smaller than this room
it's the parts are getting very
difficult to get and replace because
it's obsolete many cases
second part of the project is
a roof
we purchased our building a few years
ago as i'm sure all of you know um we
knew that there was going to be a roof
issue at that time because engineering
study was done in 2017
um we are experiencing leak in in the
roof
along with that would be replacement of
the hvac units as they are also reaching
that life life cycle
and the last area would be the uh server
room
our server room right now has a
sprinkler system in it
water sprinkler system again if
something does happen and the issue goes
off and those sprinklers go off our
servers are obviously going to be toast
so the idea would be to reconfigure the
server room to include
non-water system i can't remember the
name of it right now i apologize
and to off also reconfigure in the same
time some office space in that
reconfiguration to add some more space
we've added as you all know
kino sports betting hhr now all these
different gaming systems increasing our
staff greatly
um a lot of these things came on after
we bought the building and we are
running short on space we've all already
rented an additional space over on
off airport road
and uh we will we've outgrown that space
already it's to the maximum so we are
going to be looking to just re not add
on to the building at this point but
just reconfigure to get some more
and that covers our three main areas
okay a
question for you is the
how long does and i know it's an
estimate does your generator have uh are
is a generator good for another year
i certainly hope so
um you know it's one of those things um
they're
mickey mousing some repairs at times
when they have to to be able to come in
and do service on it
like i said it is very old i you know
it's so tough to say because things were
built differently and it could last
another 10 years
because it was well built at the time
but at the same time it could last
another year which is hard to call
what's the cost of the generator
fortunately that didn't get broken out
completely but i do have an electrical
number of 113 000 for the entire project
so i would assume the generator is
probably coming in from eighteen to a
just um
you're doing quite well for your first
capital budget um
the uh
how much space are you renting now
it's about 1800 square feet 1800 square
feet and but based on what's going on
with and you guys are kind of booming in
a nice way and for for those of us who
spend the money that you raise we thank
you
um
probably going to go up in the short
term
yeah i mean 1800 is not enough you're
gonna need five no we have 15 people in
there now um and you take my word for it
they are in 1800 square feet yes oh okay
wow and along with a little kitchenette
and the
nursery room and all those different
things that are required in there so
it's a
very tight cubicles hopefully they're
friendly to each other that's all that's
good representative
oh thank you
if you had been blessed with uh taking
care of marijuana
uh did you make any preliminary estimate
it was going to take you uh
facility-wise to handle that
lottery on the other l oh i thought you
were gonna get it
okay thank you
not seeing any other questions thank you
okay
again we're going to take a 10 minute
break and be back at 10 30 with military
i'd ask people to take their sisters
okay it's 10 30 and we have the military
and veterans affairs
sir the floor is yours thanks sir mr
gary members of the committee um for the
record i'm major general david mikulitis
the adjunct general for the new
hampshire national guard and for any
technical questions i have here with me
today major paige kamal
she leads our construction facilities
management office
so you look at the military affairs and
veteran services you should have two
sheets hopefully first sheet should have
six priorities that addresses our
military affairs portfolio
and when you go down our priorities i
just like to focus on the top
five the first two we can sort of clump
together a group together
congress has appropriated us federal
dollars in the president's future years
defense plan for military construction
projects
so you look at our top two priorities in
nashua and plymouth
those already congressionally
appropriated federal dollars we're here
seeking the state match in this capital
budget um process
to have the state match up for
25 federal to state cost share
the two top
priorities for construction military
construction a 5 000 square foot
addition in nashua and about 25 to 30
000 new armory uh the town of plymouth
when you go down priority number three
which is armory boil and roof
replacement
each of our buildings has a different
different federal state cost share you
know some buildings are 100 fairly
reimbursed some are 75 25 some are 50 50
and some 100 state general funded it's
all of a function of the sort of the
purpose or the function that that unit
does
so for example our aviation facility and
our maintenance facilities are 100
federally reimbursed
certain buildings in concord pembroke
have a 75 25 federal
state cost share
this is just yet after routine
maintenance for boiler boiler
replacement and roof replacement and
that's why it's a 75-25 cost share so we
don't get the state general funds we
cannot replace aging roofs on 30 year
old 30 year old roofs on aging buildings
priority number four is land purchase in
manchester
a strategic initiative priority for the
state of new hampshire is for us to
relocate from our existing manchester
armory
the manchester armory is approximately
eight acres of land on north elm street
it's a hundred thousand square foot
building
for the last decade or two i've been
involved with different conversations of
trying to relocate
the manchester armory
it all starts with land in the absence
of land which is a state responsibility
we cannot move the manchester armory or
relocate to another location
so based upon today's sort of a current
sort of
commercial climate for real estate um
we're estimating approximately five
million dollars to buy approximately 10
to 15 acres of land
when you go to your specific sheet
there's a typo it says five acres it
should say 15.
priority number five is nashua hazardous
material replacement uh remediation
at our national armory where we're doing
that 5 000 square foot addition we know
for a fact that in the back of the motor
pool
there's former tannery waste that's been
capped
so we have to take we have to sort of
take a re-look at the sort of
environmental uh issues at our national
parcel to determine if it will have an
impact on where we put this addition um
in that future and if we do a future
build out there
so those are top five parties from the
military affairs portfolio
if you skip through skip through a
couple of your pages you'll see another
page called veteran services
where there's two projects
both 100 federally reimbursed
and they both have to deal with the
expansion the state veterans cemetery in
bosco in
one is for niches and ones for
in-ground cremations
and those are about two and a half and
three and a half million dollars
respectively
subject to your questions that's all i
have
okay thank you
the
the armory in manchester if you could
just briefly explain
why you need a new facility and then
what what are the plans to happen with
the current facility that you have once
this new
project is is completed
so right now
the
the manchester armory sits on land owned
by the ammo skate industries
so when we vacate that land the building
and the land goes to the ammo skate
industries due to its revisionary claws
because they give us the land back in
the 1930s to build this armory
um
that's the first parcel
the army is over 80 years old
although it
meets our current needs
um it's not ideally situated for our
future
mission set so currently the unit in
there is called our field artillery
brigade headquarters they're currently
in the middle east they deploy every
four to five years so it's their fourth
deployment in 20 years
and it's a technologically advanced um
artillery unit that
when they deploy overseas
they don't have the internet sort of the
the backbone
to currently operate in that facility
with some of the networks of which they
have and we keep putting in a minor
routine repairs to try to sort of uh
bring it up to both code and to allow
them to perform their federal mission
but it's always been a challenge
so if we can find more advantageous land
um
we would the first step for us is buying
the land and then sort of working with
congress to get the appropriation for a
military construction project
you know the challenge has always been
two-fold one is the cost to buy land
we've worked with amaze skate industries
in the city of manchester to look at
land in the past and it's always been
problematic um
in a sense that it's either wetlands
waterworks land um just not conducive
for interstate access interstate access
utilities and sort of visibility for the
public to see us
so that's always been the challenge for
us
does it have to be in manchester or
what's what's the reasoning for the
keeping it in manchester
you generally speaking we would like to
be within a 15-mile radius radius of
manchester and i think the reason why is
this simple covet
right so you know everyone wants us to
move into some other location or some
other town well we just realized for the
past two years of a cover response at
those 17 armories that we had throughout
the state we use them and so the the
closer proximity that we have to the
city of manchester to support them in a
time of need i think is advantageous
both to the guard and obviously to the
city as well
okay so it's mission compatible that
yes
i don't see any other questions
hey and again for those of you who just
arrived uh
the way this is scheduled we we can't
call you before your scheduled time and
so the next one is department of
transportation at 10 45 so
we will recess and for another eight
okay i think we're ready to begin
uh department of transportation
good morning commissioner
good morning to the members of the
committee thank you for this opportunity
to present the department of
transportation's capital budget
priorities
with me today are marie mullen our
director of finance who'll be presenting
and then should you have questions we
also have our deputy commissioner andre
briere as well as our director of
aeronautics rail and transit patrick
curlihi and i'll just add it's patrick's
last uh capital budget presentation
he'll be retiring next week and so all
the difficult questions we're going to
appeal to patrick today just to test him
and so again thank you for the
opportunity to be here today um
as many agencies have testified and we
had several capital budget requests that
we were contemplating putting forward
and today we're really going to focus on
our highest priority needs and we at the
department of transportation are
organized into five divisions
finance administration
project development operations and
aeronautics rail and transit those are
our five divisions and our capital
budget requests are associated with two
divisions uh the division of operations
and then the division of aeronautics
rail and transit and we are proud to
partner with all of the transportation
agencies in the state and so today we'll
begin with our general fund request and
then we'll talk about our highway fund
requests and i'll just note on the
general fund side um our two priority
items are actually
um to secure match to federal programs
to support both our airports and our
transit agencies that we work with and
the only request that we're putting
forward that would directly impact the
department of transportation are highway
funded requests that are associated with
the division of operations
and so with that alternative is related
to the aeronautics program so these are
faa
federal faa funds and it's the airport
improvement program uh the department's
requesting 1.2 million which would
leverage nearly 70 million dollars of
federal funds
it's
anticipated that this request includes
40 projects for 12 public use airports
and it's also anticipated that there
will be federal funding for airport
infrastructure airport terminals and air
traffic control tower projects
funded by the bipartisan infrastructure
law
which require less of a match with a
zero to five percent match the aip
program
generally provides 90 federal funds with
5 percent state match and 5 match from
the local airports
so on page 3 of the of the presentation
that we have here we have a brief
listing of the typical types of projects
that go through the aip program whether
it's taxiway runway rehabilitation
etc and then on page four
we have a listing of the diff the
airports from around the state the
projected uh capital projects through
the airport master plan that these
airports will be qualifying for um with
a listing of the federal funds and then
the state match requirement for those
for those airports
and then going to page five we have some
examples of some of the
projects and pictures of the various
terminals and some of the airports and
the projects that will be undertaken
with these funds
our second request is for transit funds
so these are federal transit
administration federal funds and we're
asking for 570 000
for the transit bus replacement program
which will leverage 6.3 million in
federal funds
this program provides matching funds for
the acquisition of approximately 36
vehicles for non-profit agencies that
provide transportation for seniors and
individuals with disabilities
and also 18 bus shelters for local
public transit systems
public transportation provides access to
jobs and critical services for new
hampshire residents
this program the federal program
requires
the match to be what we have is we have
about half of the match is provided by
the state and half is provided by the
local transit agency that
match can be either 80 20 so 80 federal
funds 20 match where ten percent comes
from the state
and ten percent from the local or we
have a program that's eighty five
percent federal where seven and a half
percent comes from the state and seven
and a half percent local
and if you go to page ten
in the presentation
we have a listing there of the
request for
vehicles and bus shelters
for the from the various agencies around
the state with the required match for
both the state and the locals
on page 11 we start with some pictures
and these are are typically these are
many of the transit vehicles that will
be replaced with some of the condition
and and corrosion that has occurred on
those so we provided some examples of
the the vehicles that would be replaced
with these federal funds with utilizing
the state match
and then i just open up for any
all right my question is on the
purchasing of of buses what's what's the
useful life
these days of a of a bus say an electric
bus
um so yes as director hurley he was
sharing um we have not uh
used federal funds to acquire
any electric buses yet we're in the
process of supporting
some of our transit agencies in
acquiring electric fleet for the first
time
um
advanced transit uh we did an item
actually just approved by governor and
council an advanced transit will be the
first uh agency to have a fully electric
bus
the vehicles that we're replacing
primarily are diesel
vehicles
it really depends on the mileage but you
know approximately fleet lasts about 10
years before we replace it
if a bus is heavily utilized and of
course is problematic they'll seek to
replace it early based on the mileage
rather than the age better way to ask
the question is is there any difference
in longevity from an electric vehicle
especially a bus to one that runs on
diesel yeah again um there's not a lot
of data yet because this is a newer
industry however i will say that the
operating expenses are significantly
lower with an electric vehicle over a
traditional
diesel bus
the reason being
there's less components and parts that
need to be serviced regularly
and so that brings down the cost
significantly however the initial
purchase price is higher
currently the electric buses
are significantly more of an upfront
investment
the studies have shown that
the break-even point is around three and
a half years right now when you look at
the life cycle costs and the cheaper
cost of operating an electric vehicle
compared to a traditional
diesel
transit fleet
representative um you're not bringing
anything forward for state-owned rail
um in our original agency uh request uh
we did have a couple of items um
we you know certainly if there's uh
general fund surplus opportunities or
an opportunity to put forward additional
requests
we would
advocate for investment in our active
rail lines first and foremost we have a
number of culvert replacement projects
bridge projects as well as thai projects
that we would
really like to move forward in the next
biennium
but we'll have to wait and see what
money might be available these
two items that you have before you today
really are the highest need because
we're trying to access those federal
funds and make sure that the state can
i have to ask about an airport question
because i can't let patrick get away
without us asking about airports
i wasn't going to until you announced
that he was retiring
um
so uh i actually i'm curious about
airports and a lot of it is because i
drive by the concord airport too often
when i go i can go up to dop and i go
right by the concrete airport and i
always look at it and go you know that
building has some some potential but all
of it unrealized
um
we have i think i read from this we have
eight federally funded airports and to
what extent is that
pardon me
12. thank you
um
many of those are municipally owned
and to what extent how do we determine
what's a state responsibility what's a
town responsibility and
and in addition to that um
[Music]
do we think uh the health of the
airports is
i mean our airport's uh closing
expanding
and thank you for uh asking director
hurley that question see i this is what
this is what i'm trying to do get him to
come up
but my answer expires in six days so
that's okay
um i'd say the
most most of the airports that we're
dealing with here in in this budget
request are general aviation airports
similar to concord
they are all
uh
still open to the public they exist they
have planes based there so i would say
that it's pretty much been status quo
since around 2008.
and uh what happened in 2008 somebody
close with something
okay did things close in 2008 they
didn't close but a lot of a lot of uh
planes left the area or
especially like businesses that use that
use corporate aviation uh kind of scaled
back on that but now they've been coming
back to that
um so you know the planes have increased
over the last few years but again it's
been
a modest increase
okay
and and it to some extent with some of
the infrastructure improvements
i mean would you anticipate that
expanding i mean i doubt we're ever
going to have another airport because
you know the land issue and all that if
nothing else but
um
some could thrive
i mean i you i look at it and say go go
to nashua look at that airport that
thrives that's a general aviation
airport that thrives
okay yeah that was my question yes nash
was that way um skyhaven
does does a good business down there
concord does you go go on
during uh graduations or during uh
um
when they have the nascar races
and the airport's crucial at that point
in time
great um thank you for your answer and
thank you for your service and
congratulations on your retirement thank
you very much
since this is my first and last time to
get to ask you a question yeah
um
the airline industry as a whole is
undergoing some strenuous times right
now i mean from inability to find pilots
to fly their planes to
fuel prices which are going through the
roof
are are you anticipating any sort of
contraction in the significant
contraction in the airline industry and
if so
how will that impact uh may i guess
mainly the airport in manchester right i
i really don't have any information on
that we're pretty much the construction
group so we're the ones that go in and
make sure that the airport is safe
and that um you know things are being
done to faa standards the market itself
is more of an airport
and a airline uh decision-making process
the one thing i would add is that you
know
while the average person thinks of
commercial air travel when they think
about airports
our airports have a significant impact
on our economy not just because they
move people but because of the goods
that
are transported through the airports and
so even when we've seen a contraction in
recreational
and vacation travel
we've still seen especially during the
pandemic the
um critical role that our airports play
in our overall transportation system and
there's been a lot of expansion when it
comes to the commercial operations at
these airs at these airports across the
state
yeah manchester's in the process of
going building a new cargo facility
great thank you
good morning uh so my question is also
on the aviation side but more on the
funding in some of the summary pages it
looked like the general fund share was
around 7 million that was requested and
63 million was going to be the federal
match and i'm assuming it might
might be a 10
but it looks like in your description
that based on the
the average of like two and a half five
or ten percent it's closer to 1.2 so i
was just sort of trying to reconcile
what the general funds share
might be closer at
there's a number of different federal
programs that have different
participation requirements and so the
typical programs are 90 federal with a 5
local match and 5
state match
however in the bipartisan infrastructure
law there was some funding provided for
airports and the matching requirements
are different and so
we have tried to anticipate based on the
airport master plans what projects each
airport will undertake
and based on eligibility what the mix of
funds will be
and that's how we came up with the state
match requirement the 1.2
thank you
so uh sherry if you assistant
assistant commissioner sherry um
if you go to page four there's actually
there's a detailed breakdown there so it
in the upper box it shows that what the
commissioner was just talking about with
that 90 10
share and so that we're showing this
five percent state share so that comes
out to about 2.7 million we're only
asking for 1.2 and then that lower box
identifies where that difference is so
previously in previous bienniums we've
requested matching funds and we've had
we have some excess available so you can
see there's about 1.5 million reduction
in that below box so we're reducing our
request down to the 1.2 million for what
we we already have available from prior
biennium approvals
that's because
2020 and 2021 with the code with relief
funding
projects were allowed to use 100 federal
funding we already had the state match
authority but so we didn't use it so
and for the folks on online um
so
in previous bienniums we had requested
the match but when the coveted relief
funds came we um they provided 100
of the federal funds and we didn't
require state match so we have excess
state match for the folks at home who
true
thank you okay um if no further
questions we'll go on to the highway
fund so our first request for the
highway fund is for a little over two
million dollars for construction of our
salt and sand sheds
currently in many of the locations we
cannot store a season's worth of salt
and the shred the sheds are reaching the
end of their useful life and
environmental regulations require that
all salt be stored under cover
so if you turn to page 14
we have a listing of our oldest salt
sheds and and those that we would
anticipate uh replacing and so what we
do is with this request we'll replace as
many of these salt sheds as we can with
the the funds
that allow
and so you can see
many of these sheds here
are
near 40 years old or some are over 40
years old
and some of the pictures starting on
page 15. you can see the condition of
these sheds the deterioration
the holes in the in the siding
and especially they were built so long
ago that many of the the vehicles that
we have can't fit inside of these sheds
to move the salt efficiently so we're
looking to replace some of these oldest
sheds with with this funding and that is
our
top priority request
our second request
is related to underground
uh fuel tanks
in the in the last biennium we were not
approved generally we try to get money
every biennium so that we can um
you know
replace these tanks as needed during
their replacement life cycle but in the
last biennium we did not receive funds
for this so we've had to defer tank
replacements for the last couple of
years
currently we have about 40 sites that
have underground storage tanks that are
in excess of 25 years old
or nearing their life expectancy and so
the perfect
potential for environmental damage
compliance and extensive repairs
increases considerably as these
underground storage tanks are aging
we're requesting approximately 2 million
dollars
for that
and if you go to page
20 in the book
we've listed some of our oldest fuel
tanks and with this two million dollars
we would reconstruct as many of these
fuel tanks as would allow with those
funds you can see that many of these are
significantly beyond the the estimated
useful life of the tanks at over you
know 34 35 years old
and that's what we would request these
funds for
our last uh
priority request today is for five
million dollars for the improvement of
crew quarters
at our patrol sheds statewide
the improvements for these crest route
uh crew rest areas are necessary um due
to the winter activities the 24 7 nature
during storms and the required safety
breaks that are required we also need to
comply with current building codes and
safety fire marshal findings that we've
had previously
so the 5 million dollars would provide
improvements to as many of the nearly 90
dot patrol shed statewide
and on page 24 of our presentation
we've included some pictures there
as to examples of the crew quarters that
we currently have
and you know some of the safety issues
potentially the first picture on page 24
you can see
the crew quarters are right next to a
budding the the heating system
and probably not a
good safety protocol to have our
employees sleeping and resting in those
areas
during snowstorms so that that's our
final request on the that we're
presenting on the highway fund and
opening up to any questions
what's the age of the salt sheds now
especially these pictures that you've
um on page 14 we have a list of the
locations under item number three that
we would intend to
address with these funds
and you'll see i see the okay i see the
agency they rage in age from 19 to 44
years
and with some of these facilities it's
not
just the age of them but salt
has obviously significant damage so when
you have wooden structures and things so
you know salt can deteriorate those very
quickly as compared to a normal building
the other challenge is you know we try
to take advantage of
competitive pricing and acquire a full
year's worth of salt
and sort of hedge against inflation when
costs are increasing and currently we
don't have sufficient space to store a
full year's worth of salt some of our
sheds are still on the smaller side so
as we replace the older infrastructure
we're making sure that we size it
appropriately so that we can
not only have efficient operations as
marie was saying with more space to let
the equipment operate within the shed
but then also to make sure that we have
the capacity to store the material that
we need
how many sheds do you have statewide
um there's around
um
90 locations
okay
and so i take it you you build them
periodically and
yeah this is a recurring capital budget
request um each biennium we're asking
for the funds to replace a certain
numbers so we can gradually address all
um of the 40 sites that have fuel tanks
um how many tanks are
does that comprise is it is it more than
just 40 tanks
yeah some of the tanks are combined
sites for both diesel and unleaded so
there's numerous tanks at each location
and are there any
you know building fuel tanks uh on those
sites that need to be replaced as well
i don't believe this item addresses any
fuel tanks specifically for
the gas
storage
but
we certainly have other needs when it
comes to replacing
the tanks associated with our facilities
themselves
how many hi
um how many um
it says you have 40 fuel sites that have
underground storage tanks uh
silly question but do you have any that
don't the weather tank isn't underground
is is 40 the is the fuel distribution
network
40 sites
no we have 40 sites that are 25 years um
of age or older and so uh the request is
associated with addressing those
locations
again this is a recurring capital budget
term request because we try to each
biennium address a certain number of
tanks i just want to reassure you that
we are in compliance with all
environmental standards but of course
the risks and when you have older
equipment increase significantly as
marie shared we did not receive funding
through the last capital budget for fuel
sites and so that's why we really have
this is a high priority need in this
cycle because we don't want to go four
years without addressing some of these
locations
so you have 40 sites that are over 25
years old how many sites total
ballpark
i think we have again around
not every shed has fuel however
um
we have
locations that are not at a shed for
example here in concord there's one on
hazen drive that's not one of our
locations but they're generally
co-located with other i know this is
off-subject they're generally co-located
with other facilities yes um to aid with
our operations it makes sense to have
fuel sites um
both you know where the trucks operate
but then also the staff that are
responsible for those facilities are
there to provide day-to-day oversight of
the fuel site
thanks
representative uh commissioner
looking at another agency's request
uh
have
do you talk with with safety about what
they are proposing to use highway funds
in the next capital budget
so in the early phase of the budget
process each agency develops their own
list of needs i'm certainly as we
move into
the later phases will be collaborating
with safety um you know one of the
things that was done during the last
budget was an assessment of you know how
much borrowing could be sustained with
the highway fund and its current
revenues
and um so that's the one thing to stress
is you know while
generally we've talked about a general
fund
capital budget around 125 million we'll
have to collaborate with safety to
understand what the appropriate amount
of borrowing would be
based on general fund revenue
projections
not seeing any other questions thank you
very much
congratulations and good luck on your
retirement
okay
again we have another built-in break
into the schedule and we'll be back at
a six minute recess and we'll be back at
okay it's 11 15
requests that
and i'd like to invite up
representatives of the judicial branch
hello
good morning yeah we before we begin i
wanted to i've been waiting to do this
for for two days and that is i dare
correct
uh the commissioner to my right here and
that he said repeatedly that the dra is
the nicest building in state government
having worked at the dra it is a
beautiful building
it's number two on my list
and i've talked to this boat before the
supreme court is the nicest building in
state government
and no one would know
it's 50 years old
except we have our historic designation
plaque now so i'm justice hans marconi
i'm here to support diane martin our
executive director and she will take it
away okay please begin thank you hi
diane martin director of the
administrative office of the courts i
like to think that where we are located
right now is also very nice at one
hi senator
okay so we only have one
capital budget request that for this
biennium it is fairly straightforward it
builds off of work that justice hans
marconi started in the last biennium to
digitize some of the old book collection
that is housed in the
basement of the supreme court right now
without any real protection and
sort of incl in conjunction with this we
are also working on creating
an archive room in the basement where
some of these older uh records and books
can be placed but the safest thing to do
obviously is to digitize them and to
make them available electronically to
people so that they can access them
without actually seeing
or touching them so we can preserve them
but i'm going to turn it over to justice
hans marconi to really speak to the
merits of the project
you can imagine my surprise when i
joined the court and was assigned to be
the library judge so housed in the
supreme court building is the king law
library it is
i'll call it administratively connected
with the court it is the state's only
public law library it is the library of
record it is the only place that the
public can go in and get legal resources
um
and it's housed in our building and our
librarian works with other public
libraries to make sure those resources
are accessible throughout the state but
the universities the federal court those
law libraries have over the years been
i'll say privatized but there is no
public access so in my
job as library judge i discovered mary
searle's our librarian of course knew
they were there we have case books in
the basement on shelves and i gave a
presentation right before covid to the
joint legislative historical committee
on this
fact that we have these old case books
that range from 1849
to 1970
not so old 1849 very old and beyond that
we have some rare books and some
documents um docket books that precede
that
in these case books because what
happened were the judges on the supreme
court road circuit and they heard cases
and then at the end of the case all the
documents whether there was sheriff's
notices deeds the court's notes the
pleadings of the parties were put
together and then cases were stacked up
and when it got to a critical mass they
stitched them into books
so in these books are archival documents
old paper inc charles doe writings um
the mary baker eddie cases the original
mary baker eddy trust cases which
in recent decades
because the litigation's been ongoing
for so long or it starts anew people do
come to research those old materials we
also have the hairy hand case which is a
law school favorite it is well known it
is a well-known tort case involving
medical malpractice where a doctor
grafted skin that grew hair onto a palm
injury and so the gent ended up with a
hairy hand and sued
so these are historical they're also
valuable research documents
this project in 2018 and you have in
your materials the northeast document
conservation center took a look at them
put together a proposal two million
dollars to digitize
and preserve all those papers now
obviously some of the
my focus is the oldest and so they broke
the project into three parts to deal
with the oldest most fragile documents
first and then as we go through time to
preserve the later documents we will
then have a gap between 77 and today
when things have moved to a digital
process but that's beyond
my focus at the moment so what we did
last year we had a small appropriation
fifty thousand dollars we have
started on processing the first old case
books so we'll have something to show
you
shortly which they dis bind they take
the documents they preserve them in acid
free paper they go on shelves
and then the
the electronic version is available for
research purposes and if someone needs
to come in to get to the actual
artifact we can produce that in a more
rare book fashion so right now these
things are on a shelf in the basement
thank goodness we have a nice building
it hasn't leaked
but we really need to do something to
better preserve these documents for the
state because they aren't just court
document their documents their state
artifacts originally the library was
intended to have a rare book room that
never happened when the building was
built
it's now a conference room so we have
plans in the works not part of this
project to identify space to have
climate controlled so that when we get
these documents preserved we have a
place to store them long-term so this is
just the um
preservation digitization piece of it
and so ultimately it will be a
multi-year process and the final thing
mary our librarian told me is with state
funding
she will have the ability to seek some
additional funding from places like the
library of congress and some federal
grants that are geared toward
preserving
old documents so
this is a start and it is
frankly long overdue and i'm happy to
take questions
you said two million was the total
figure to get all the
all the uh
um i just want to say first of all i
want to thank the supreme court for
sending my um favorite justice and i
only i'm sorry the chief isn't here to
hear me say that
i'll be sure to tell him thank you i
would appreciate that
i would like that
um
i had the privilege of uh um
working with justice marconi on a tour
um of uh of she took me in the basement
and showed me the books
um and it was appalling right it was
wonderful and appalling at the same time
and i think this is a wonderful request
and um
um
i think there's a microwave in the same
room right
the books are on shelves outside of the
shredding
closet so when it's important not to get
confused just go down and get shredded
the dust from the documents goes and i'm
told
by northeast document center that that's
a really bad thing so yes so i think it
and i think it's great that we're gonna
we're gonna um fix up space in the
probably in the basement to to to have a
room will some of this well some of the
the
um most interesting documents eventually
be on display somewhere that's what
we're
so we have the rare book room
we hope also to have a
space for researchers to work with the
materials but then we also want to have
display space in the upper floors of the
library so that the public we get
student groups in we get the public in
of course using the library and so a lot
of these things we have a great place to
showcase some of the important stuff
that we have
so
yes
good you were and you were telling me
right before we um came on air so to
speak
about
the notion of many of the court
documents are sort of scattered about
uh yes this is
nicely these books are in one place but
i have also learned through
working with the supreme court society
talking to the state archivist talking
to clerks in our superior courts
there are documents including case
documents supreme court documents that
are just
scattered about and so
big picture
we'd love this is a start and we'd love
to
um proceed with preserving this sort of
legal history of the state and so the
supreme court society has worked on a
project to identify
important cases in the law so that we
can at least start um in a prioritized
way to draw those in
as well
thank you
i know that um repeated use and
environment are
the antithesis of good book preservation
uh is it do you have any estimate on on
how much material this is probably maybe
just a guess at this point you've lost
due to those conditions
so far
and i think it's
it's a you know hat tip to whoever built
our building we haven't lost
anything some of the pages in some of
the older books when mary gets them out
with the white gloves
they're
fragile
but we haven't had any of the
total books you know disintegrate and we
haven't had any of the old books or old
documents um disintegrate so far so it
is really a a testament to the building
and also the time is right to start this
project
yeah thank you
representative
um
you did mention that it would cost about
2 million to do all of them if
if you got the entire 2 million would
you be able to spend it all in one
biennium or is the the plan that we
started on two years ago the way to go
do it and do it right over a period as
as we go forward
i am sure that northeast document
conservation center would ramp up and do
it all in one biennium
again i am most concerned with the
oldest first
so
i think a staged proposal and you're
involved we had we talked about this
two years ago and i'm sure this price
from 2018 might have gone up
but i think staging it makes sense
absolutely
thank you very much
uh p's development authority is next up
i'd like to invite you to come up for
[Music]
excuse me uh good morning mr chairman
members of the committee and staff i'm
geno marconi i'm the director at the
new hampshire port authority which is a
division of the peas development
authority with me is uh
the p's executive director paul breen
and also with us is uh susie anzalone
who is our finance director
uh so what you have before you today is
is a couple of requests uh one of which
uh we're going to
withdraw from from the capital budget
because uh
uh we got some funding uh through the
opera program but the first one you have
is a is a small dredging project
um
when
new hampshire d.o.t built the sarah
mildred long bridge
we lost part of our facility down there
and new hampshire d.o.t and federal
highway agreed to give us a
functional replacement to make us whole
again and part of that project is is
dredging and it's a it's a big piece of
uh dredge in
where the new facility is going to be
added on to
but we also need to do a small dredge
alongside the face of the pier it's
i call it a maintenance dredge the army
corps of engineers said no it's a it's a
separate project
but uh
it would be advantageous for us to do
that maintenance dredge at the same time
that uh the functional replacement
project is so that's what this first
request you have here for six hundred
and twenty one thousand dollars
uh it's it's based on uh current uh
costs for dredge material
it's a really small project it's about
thirteen hundred cubic yards but we to
do that at the same time that the the
functional replacement project is being
done and that whole project's 34 million
dollars so
and then this the second project you
have in there is uh uh funds to do uh
decking and cross bracing uh on the
portsmouth commercial fish pier uh we'd
like to withdraw that one because as i
said last week
governor and council and the
fiscal committee approved that that
and then the third one is uh is an
important project uh it's it's a uh you
know it's out a little bit further than
the other ones
um
i'll give you a little history a couple
of years ago the sea wall at the
portsmouth fish pier
failed
and the legislature funded
appropriated 3.25 million dollars to do
that project that project's been
completed
but the building that's there was built
in
1977 78 and uh it's it's a wood building
and in that environment
the building's old it's falling apart
it really needs to be replaced and
that's what this request is for
inside that building are two
refrigerated cold storage facilities
some small office space and a work area
where
seafood can be handled
out of the sun especially in the
summertime and that's what that request
there is is for
a million five
two three to replace that building at
the portsmouth commercial fish pier and
how excuse me how long how large is the
building in in portsmouth on the fishing
pier
the fish
fifty six hundred fifty six hundred i
and is there the cost just to replace
the building or the building and the
equipment inside including um there is
some equipment
if i can give you a little bit more
background please
originally we had been planning on
uh building a whole new building and
thinking about relocating it on the
property to make the facility more
efficient for trucks loading and
unloading but when we were doing the
seawall because it was so close to the
edge of the wall
when we dug down alongside of it we
realized that the footings in the in
were in really good shape uh during the
project because of the pile driving and
the heavy equipment running around
the floor drain in in the two coolers
and in the work area uh failed they were
old and the vibrating everything they
failed so
uh we went in and saw cut the floor out
to replace the drains and we didn't have
any as built of the of the building
we thought there was you know eight to
ten inches of concrete on the floor
found out that the floor was 19 inches
thick
so we put in new new floor drains we've
got new utilities going in there now
water and electricity it's all been
upgraded so we step back and say you
know why do we want to reinvent the
wheel here why don't we just replace the
building on the existing footprint
because the foundation utilities are all
still there so
that's that's why we came up with a much
reduced estimate on what what needs to
be done
the only
caveat with the building is that
back in the 70s when the state bought
this piece of property
the state bought the shoreline on pierce
island from the city of portsmouth for a
dollar
and then they built
uh a revetment and they and when they
when they dredged for the fish pier that
was the where they uh disposed of the
spoils which made the
actual land that the facility is on
um
in that
purchase of the property there are a
couple of deed restrictions one is if if
it's ever not used for commercial
fishing reverse back to the city and two
is that any structures on the facility
have to be architecturally compatible
with the neighborhood so that's one of
the things that we will have to work
with the city on because
it's located in the historic district of
portsmouth and
you know we have a obligation to make
those facilities
compatible with the city
but i'm just going to note that it's um
it's quite rare that the capital budget
hearings are concluded with a husband
and wife tag team
and so i certainly appreciate that
well she is the smarter of the two of us
it's commissioner well you said that not
me
well thank you very much mr chairman
members of the committee and
and especially a lot of thanks to
steve and chris for
helping me out as i venture on in this
position
thank you very much thank you thank you
and with that
uh i just want to give a couple of thank
yous first to our legislative side both
from the the senate and the house for
for attending these hearings and
participating i think there there is
even we have people here who are who are
decided not to run again
and but they still care enough about
what goes on in the state of new
hampshire to spend a beautiful summer
day
here with us over the last two days so
charlie
thank you very much
i also like to to thank
a huge shout out not only to all the
members of the community but especially
department administrative services
who did a fantastic job uh despite even
last-minute changes major changes at the
last minute and handled it in an
extremely professional way so couldn't
have done it without you thank you
it's worth noting that don howe did a
ton of work um on the logistical side
and then
michelle carraway and her team
does a lot of work and
and i just sit here
and just for those who may be listening
in if you could just touch on
now that you've heard all of this from
the governor's perspective what happens
now with all the information you got
well with all the information we got now
we go back and i uh talk to the governor
and we go through and
his target is 125 million so
we need to whittle down what was roughly
330 million down to 125 million he then
makes that recommendation
to the legislature and the legislature
takes it from there
and then
with any luck the governor will see it
with that the governor's capital budget
you